and obviously a lot of pressure on you
playing Elton but then Bernie Taupin is
this strange man in that you know we all
know the name but actually people don't
already looks like people don't know
what he sounds like yeah is that freeing
or did you still feel like I
responsibilities to the man it is
nothing like what Terran must have felt
in terms of approaching the role and and
and you know the concept of him playing
John you know Bernie lives in relative
anonymity lives in Santa Barbara very
happily with his wife Heather and I
think he enjoys that sense of anonymity
but their connection has last know there
is lasted many decades there is an
essential need that they both have I
don't think that they could have done it
without each other
really and of course you didn't just
meet out and you sort of become friends
you've stayed in his house in the
example you yes yeah it was my
girlfriend and I went and stayed without
the David for a few nights probably
about a year ago and it was okay really
well and we all having really lovely
time and then we we got we Alan David
teetotal but we got a little bit drunk I
got caught by the head of his security
raiding his larder at three in the
morning so so grim and I thought Elton
didn't know and the following day I was
just kind of like going about you know
going about the conversation you spent
you know you were a little [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]